happy hos are hatin and hatin hoes ain't
happy I think probably the most random
thing that I organize is the middle
console of my car I have everything in a
ziplock bags labeled so think that's a
little weird but I'm a little weird we
have one family chat with the boys
included we have one group chat would
just the sisters and my mom we have one
group chat with just Kourtney Kim and I
and then we have one group chat with
just the sisters and without my mom
naughty when you ain't happy you got to
be hatin and so I feel like people
cannot stand when other people are happy
for some reason it's a really sad truth
and we're so United and we're so happy
and we're also super honest about when
something bad does happen to us and I
think people cannot understand how we
become stronger and more united rather
than fall apart like that's people's
greatest wish is probably that we all
end up stabbing one another and like
hating each other but in fact you become
more in love with one another
[Music]
moisturize moisturize moisturize when I
go to bed at night I'm like a slip and
slide I am covered in oil and I don't
care
god bless whoever sleeps next to me
because it's just gross but it's okay I
look perfect
I really do believe in the buddy system
and working out I think that has really
helped me stay motivated and working out
because you have days that you do not
want to get out of bed and I love the
buddy system I think your friends should
be like you I should share the same
hobbies and you guys kind of get
competitive with one another I mean
literally the fact that I brought home
shorty a homeless person that I just met
at the back of - like thinking of the
things I did are really unsafe shorty
was so cute and sweet and thank God he
was sweet but what if he was like some
crazy serial killer who killed all of us
I don't care if people make fun of us if
people are for us or against us like I
don't really give a [ __ ] I'm not here to
please every human being in the world
and here just for me so I find the memes
to be hysterical and 24 talking about me
you obviously know about me so keep the
memes coming [ __ ] know I feel like I
literally tell you guys everything Jesus
that's why I am in the place that I am
always in trouble
[Music]